Hey, guys!
Welcome back thanks for joining us today on the king of random we've often done some chemistry experiments that are hard to do at home
Because it's hard to get your hands on the right chemicals or it's a little too dangerous
Well today we've got some experiments that are easy, and safe to do at home with
Chemicals that are very readily available all of the experiments, we'll do today will involve milk as a
Main ingredient the first experiment we're
gonna
Try, involves milk and a bottle of cola all the milk is almost ph neutral some of the components in it react
Interestingly with the acids and bases found in other chemicals we're
Gonna, try pouring, some milk into one of these cola
Bottles and watch what happens as it reacts with the acid in the soda alright, we want to let?
A little bit of the gas escape otherwise it's gonna overflow. And spill over also probably just pour out
A little bit of the soda before we add our milk just to make more space and i have also shaken it up and slowly
Opened it to try and take out, some of the extra bubbles
Now i'll pour in the milk and we'll let it sit for a, while to watch what happens
It's gonna react and hopefully not overflow
That's one of the, main reasons i tried to get rid of some of the extra bubbles cuz
If i'd done that when it was new it probably would have just exploded everywhere
Wow that can be cool it's not what we're, going for today, oh?
This is dangerous because if i don't hold it tight enough it's just gonna explode everywhere i think it's going to explode everywhere
oh
All right almost unscathed just got a little bit in there and mix this up a little bit
You can, already, see what's starting to happen
There's little flecks and bits visible floating around in the soda so now, we're just, gonna take this and we're gonna let
It sit for about 45 minutes and watch what happens to it
All right our bottle of coke, and milk has now been sitting for a little over an hour and you can
See how much it's weirdly separated out to
Be honest i'm not sure what exactly the different components here are we've got some sort of
Bubbly, foam up at the top
And we've got this darker brown
Disgusting whatever it is down at the bottom and a clear liquid i mean it's clear
It's murky looks kind of like, swamp water but you can, see through it that's for sure
Alright let's open it up see what we've got inside
Well that's pretty interesting all the bubbles escaping our lifting some of the mix with it
It still smells like cola
That looks really gross but i am gonna try a little bit of this should just be cola and milk but
Okay, weirdly enough that actually just, still tastes like cola
Right this clear gross liquid it tastes like cola, still weird
Now we're gonna do an experiment that i learned way?
Back in elementary school and i've always thought it looks really cool it involves using milk food coloring and a little bit of dish soap
The setup is very simple find a nice shallow. Pan or plate and fill it with, about half an inch of milk
After you filled your container with a shallow
Layer of milk take, your pick of food coloring and drop a few drops around
your
Milk now i have my container of dish soap and you can either drip it in just with single drops or if you have a
Long bamboo skewer or something similar you can touch that into the soap and then touch it into the milk near the food coloring
boom
The, soap starts reacting with the milk and makes it spread out in these, weird smoke like patterns
And when it runs into the food coloring it spreads that out in its, own smoke, like patterns that run
across the surface of the milk
It's a really cool, swirling patterns doing this
Alright it's already kind of swirled up but i am gonna
Try, just dripping in a drop of soap and see if that does anything at. This point
Yes it does look at that it just flies, away
That's pretty fun let's try a couple different colors and do this again
so
What's happening here the soap lands on the milk but it doesn't mix into it it starts dissolving over the surface of the milk and
As it dissolves it spreads out into incredibly thin layers
the food coloring is less dense than the milk and so it tends to sit on the surface of it
So as the soap is moving around spreading out it pulls and pushes the food coloring, along with it the soap
Begins to bind to the fat in the milk, which
Is what makes it keep moving and swirling around even after it's been in the milk for a, while
Our next experiment
Is somewhat inspired by those videos you've probably seen of making elephant toothpaste
That's a combination of chemicals that sort of combines quickly and explodes out in this really thick dense foam what
We'll do isn't quite as explosive or rigid but it is impressively similar how
Thick, and fast it foams up the first step is to just pour about half cup. Of milk in each plastic
Cup, now, we have here some baking, soda, and some citric acid one is a fairly strong base and the other as its
Name implies is an acid if you
Want to buy citric acid it's usually sold with canning supplies in your grocery store this is a powdered
Crystalline acid this is the same stuff that makes lemons and limes sour you, may have experienced some point
Your life candy that's coated with, this stuff it's just a, white powder but it's extremely tart
Mmm yep
If you, ever had warheads
This, is what's on the outside of them i'm going to add one tablespoon of baking?
Soda - 1 cup and 1 tablespoon of citric acid to the other
Citric acid into the milk
Stir up both of those and you can, see that i'm doing this on a cookie sheet because
when i add one of these milks to the other one
It's just gonna immediately turn into a foam that sprays up out of the cup, so here goes
Boom it erupts all over
and it's like a really thick foam -
It holds its shape pretty, well doesn't just collapse
Do that there you go
Nice thick milk foam i'm gonna taste it
mmm
Yeah, that's, gross it's like, a little bit sour because of the citric acid
But it also has like the baking, soda taste which is sort of oh i?
Know salty but?
If something can taste powdery then baking, soda tastes powdery i want to try that, again, but i'm gonna
Add food coloring to the milk before i combine them and see if we can get like a colored elephant toothpaste coming out of their
Home for a bright green sort of booze so i'm gonna, add some green to one side it's some yellow to the other
Baking, soda in one citric acid in the other
those together and
Colored milk foam eruption
Right and milk volcano in three two one hopefully ah
There you go!
That's a way better volcano than baking, soda and vinegar
Yeah, it slowly oozed off everything
Got like this nice red color down here
Milk lava
And now for one final experiment we'll show
You, how to take milk and vinegar and turn them into a form of plastic the first step is we want to take
About one cup of milk and heat it up on the stove you
Want to heat the milk up to a point
Where it's just barely too hot to touch don't let it boil
Once your milk is hot remove it from the heat and add four teaspoons of white vinegar
You, should be able to see the vinegar reacting with, the milk pretty much immediately as you
Stir the vinegar, it will very quickly start clumping into a disgusting mess
You can, see it separating out into clear liquid, and some white stringy stuff
Once it's mixed in and really separated pour your whole mixture through a strainer
This will separate out the clear liquid and the white goop
What you should be left with is a soft white substance that kind of looks like you squished up a marshmallow
You can, rinse this off with cool, water to make it easier to handle
Now this white mush is mostly made up of what's called milk casein one of the components in your milk
I'm just gonna squish it between a couple of paper towels to try and help and dry it off a little more
There you have it now this substance which right now is behaving sort of like a slightly crumbly
Clay, will eventually dry to become a fairly hard plastic it's
Also interesting when i first mixed this up i thought that it would smell terrible because it's basically made of vinegar and curdled
Milk but it really doesn't have much smell at all i'm, also, gonna taste it even though i think it might be gross
hmm
kind of a gross texture
Like if you chewed up string cheese, and then spat it out it's
About like that texture but it really, doesn't taste like anything it doesn't taste like, milk it definitely doesn't taste like
Vinegar, it's just kind of
There and try and form this into a triangle like the king of random symbol
to
Be honest i worked as a sculptor for a few years?
This is not the nicest f to sculpt with but it is pretty neat that it's just made of milk and vinegar
I'm just gonna take this triangle i'm gonna put it up on the stealth shelf for a few
Days, and we're just, gonna see what happens to it we've now
Let our vinegar and milk composite sit for several weeks and really let it dry out and holy cow
This, thing is just hard plastic at. This point you see if i can, use pliers and break it
Yep, with pliers i can, break it
There we go?
Interesting it does have a little bit of variance of texture running through it looks like there's sort of an
Outside and then an inner core probably just where it dried faster and slower just see if you can, sand it with sandpaper
And sand it quite, well with the sandpaper in fact
It's surprisingly smooth
There's the rough side and then here's the side that we've sanded down
All right i was so curious, about, what i could
Do with this that i just grabbed the sandpaper and i carved it down into something of an arrowhead shape
It's not really, sharp it's it's angled but
You'd never be worried, about cutting yourself with something like
this it holds its shape i suppose if that were on a
Stick and it were traveling fast enough it could, stab through something it is fairly lightweight, so i'm not sure how
Much weight it would be offering to your arrow to really guide it but you know it does shape pretty, well surprisingly, well actually
There you have it a few simple chemistry experiments that you can, do at home that use milk as the primary ingredient
we mix milk with, some cola in a
Soda bottle and watched it separated into this murky clear liquid, and then this brown muddy looking sludge down at the bottom
some food coloring
And dish soap dripped onto the surface of the milk gives us some amazing. Swirling patterns as the
dissolves onto the surface of the milk and pushes the food color and all around it when we mix citric acid and baking soda in
Cups of milk and then combine the two, we get a?
Quick rising thick, dense milk foam which sort of erupts out looks a lot
Like elephant toothpaste that effect is even cooler when you?
Add some food coloring to it might be a good experiment if you ever need to make yourself a science fair volcano when
We combine warm milk with, white vinegar some of the components of the milk separate, and we're able to strain out the milk casein
Which is sort of like a?
Gummy, clay, that we can
Form into different shapes and then it dries out into a hard plastic if you've got any ideas of things you
Want to see us try with the milk and vinegar plastic let us know maybe, we'll try it out
Thanks, guys, for joining us for these experiments. Today and we'll see you in the next one talk to you then
You're, not gonna put in a vacuum chamber
Nothing will happen it's solid plastic this is why you're not supposed to blow. Bubbles in your
Milk this is where your parents were afraid of?
Kind of reminds me of intestines you got like this
Hey, guys if you, want to catch up with some of the things i'm doing in my personal life, come follow
Me on instagram and twitter at the king of random i post stories and updates as often as i can and it's really the best
Way to connect with, me directly i'll see you there